et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
michel duclos bonjour bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci d'être là
ancien ambassadeur conseiller spécial à
l'institut de l'institut montaigne est
votre dernière parution la france dans
le bouleversement du monde qui est sorti
il ya quelques temps tu oses édition de
l'observatoire vous avez été en poste
pendant plusieurs années à michel duclos
en syrie ambassadeur de france à damas
terrain que vous connaissez très bien
dans les méthodes qui sont celles de
l'armée russe en ukraine siège des
villes mélange de promesses de trêve pas
toujours tenues et de bombardement comme
celui hier sur l'hôpital pour enfants de
marioupol est-ce que vous reconnaissez
les méthodes qui ont été employées en
syrie complètement et justement avec
cette signature particulière du régime
de poutine qui est de viser les hôpitaux
et les structures hospitalières bientôt
les marchés tous les endroits où les
gens se peuvent se se retrouver qui est
combinée effectivement avec ce qu'on
appelle une guerre de siège mais c'est
une façon pudique de dire les
bombardements et ses fausses ouverture
de couloirs humanitaires ou ou trêve
provisoire qui servent à légitimer les
bombardements par ailleurs et à
démoraliser les populations est ce que
l'on peut dire en ce sens que la syrie a
pu être une forme de laboratoire
stratégique pour l'armée russe on peut
le dire et d'ailleurs c'est probablement
une des choses qui
peut-être vont rendre les choses plus
difficiles ou russes parce que le
théâtre ukrainien n'est pas le théâtre
syrien et effectivement il transfère en
ukraine ça me frappe beaucoup des
méthodes qui vont utiliser en syrie y
compris par exemple sur le plan du
vocabulaire évidemment il ne parle pas
de deux terroristes
djihadistes sait mais il parle de noisy
et donc le point de départ c'est
diaboliser l'adversaire et ensuite le
traiter avec ces méthodes que vous avez
décrite vous parliez de terrain
différent je crois qu'il ya un facteur
météorologique aussi qui est très
différente bien sûr de celui de la syrie
on parle de cette saison qui approche
qui pourrait être défavorable aux chars
russes une pas sûr que ce soit peut-être
votre votre domaine de compétences et
puis le pentagone affirme aussi que
faut-il en penser que la la russie
recrute des mercenaires syrien pour
aller se battre aux côtés de soldats
russes c'est c'est plausible c'est
plausible alors ce qu'on sait c'est que
wagner effectivement fait de la
publicité en syrie pour l'instant si
j'ai bien compris on n'a pas encore de
preuves qui effectivement des transferts
qui ait lieu mais c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait en libye donc c'est très possible
qu'il le fasse aussi en ukraine je crois
que une des différences c'est que
justement les occidentaux en syrie ont
beaucoup hésité à mai
les groupes auquel s'est attaqué la
russie et le régime de damas parce que
j'avais peur justement que ça tombe dans
les mains de
des jihadistes là c'est un peu différent
et donc cette fois ci du côté occidental
il eut beaucoup moins d'hésitation je
voudrais qu'on va y revenir dans un
instant précisément sur les européens
pour revenir à ce parallèle que certains
font entre la syrie et l'ukraine bien
sûr il ne s'agit pas des mêmes garder
même belligérants est la même du même
terrain mais certains observateurs font
aussi un parallèle depuis quelques jours
entre vladimir poutine et bachar
el-assad est ce que ce parallèle vous
paraît pertinent qu'est ce que ces deux
hommes montent en commun alors c'est
très troublant parce que dans un livre
précédent qui s'appelait la longue nuit
syrienne je faisais un portrait de
d'assad et ce qui est frappant c'est que
ça ne m'a jamais été évidemment un
intendant neeman gentleman et son
dernier occidental est trompeur bien sûr
mais c'était un autoritaire un peu
classique auquel ont donné la réputation
d'être un modernisateur et un moment
donné il a basculé dans le crime de
masse et chez
chez pauline vous avez un homme qui est
et a toujours été un dictateur mais
qu'on considéré comme rationnel
calculateur prudent d'ailleurs chaque
fois qu'il a fait des coups c'était la
crimée la sionis était toujours
assez mesuré il ne prenait pas trop de
risques avec des enjeux aussi à la
hauteur des risques c'était
proportionnelle là on a l'impression
contraire qui joue son va-tout de façon
avec une sorte de pulsion être nos
nationalistes qui correspond pas au foot
in que les occidentaux
s'imaginait deux hommes qui ont fait le
choix du pire et quoi qu'il en coûte je
crois oui deux hommes chez qui tout
bascule
et qui sont emportés
une espèce de descente aux enfers pour
les autres dans lequel eux mêmes sont
appliquées bien sûr sauf que bachar al
assad est toujours au pouvoir
aujourd'hui
d'aucuns disent que pour vladimir
poutine ce ne sera pas tenable que d'une
certaine façon il a signé son arrêt de
mort en tout cas politique ou en tout
cas au pouvoir avec cette guerre en
ukraine c'est ce que vous pensez aussi
je pense que évidemment la très grande
différence c'est que les occidentaux
font
donc jamais accordé à la syrie une
importance capitale ça tu arrêter
un peu marginale alors moi pour nous
français qui avons des liens charnels
historique humain avec la syrie mais
pour les états unis ou pour d'autres le
ciri stains théâtre secondaire la russie
évidemment avec la chine c'est l'un des
deux grands adversaires
du camp autoritaire et c'est probable
qu'on laissera pas poutine s'en tirait
aussi facilement que ça ne s'en est tiré
est ce que vous direz que les européens
paient aujourd'hui c'est en substance ce
que disait encore hier soir l'ancien
président françois hollande qui
européens paient aujourd'hui d'avoir
vous le disiez tout à l'heure détourner
les yeux au moins en syrie ou laisser
faire ou du moins c'est bon c'est mon
analyse c'est à dire que notamment le
fameux refus d'obama de frapper
assad la ligne rouge a donné le signal
aux russes que décidément les
occidentaux ne voudrait plus qu'ils
avaient perdu toute envie de se battre
qu'il n'y avait plus aucun aucune
réaction en tous les cas de type
militaire à craindre alors il est bien
vu qu'il y aura des réactions de type
sanctions économiques mais il pensait
pouvoir les gérer comme d'ailleurs sade
cher les sanctions de l'occident donc
effectivement je suis pas comme beaucoup
de gens convaincus que la faiblesse dont
nous avons fait preuve en syrie est à
l'origine de l'audace de poutine en
ukraine et puis après il ya eu d'autres
champs dans lequel s'est exprimée
bladimir poutine notamment la crimée la
géorgie à ceci près michel dupiot que la
syrie du milieu d année 2010 n'est pas
l'ukraine de 2022 vous lisiez tout à
l'heure les européens cette fois ci ne
veulent pas en tout cas veulent montrer
qu'ils ne détourne pas les yeux tout en
marchant sur une ligne de crête très
compliqué on le voit sur la question de
l'aide militaire que l'on peut que l'on
doit que l'on devrait apporter à
l'ukraine et parce que vivant une des
grandes différences entre assad et
poutine c'est que poutine est l'étape et
elle était d'un arsenal nucléaire
considérable et donc il est impossible
pour les pays de l'otan d'apparaître
comme on dit comco belligérants car à ce
moment là un poutine acculé parce que là
il est quand même dans une impasse même
par être pas s'imaginer que cette
impasse et les complète il est quand
même dans un moment de grande difficulté
une forme d'impasse ça peut être comme
un animal blessé il peut être conduit à
prendre des risques fo y compris en
matière d'extension du conflit
géographiquement s'en prenant des pays
de l'otan et verticalement en ayant
recours à des armes de destruction
massive et là aussi encore un parallèle
avec la syrie et vous savez chaque fois
que assad les utiliser l'armé chimique
la propagande russe
laisser penser que les groupes rebelles
à utiliser leurs mimiques donc cette
pièce de jeu de miroirs vicieux se
retrouve en ukraine l'europe en face
c'est forcé de mener ce qu'on appelle
une guerre hybride
je pense est un des nombreux paradoxes
de cette situation puisque c'est le
général guère asimov qui a théorisé la
le conseillerais de gates et le chef
d'état major russe
c'est à dire que puisque on peut pas
résistez directement par les armes à la
russie on est contraint de le faire si
possible en armant les ukrainiens et
surtout en attaquant la russie sur
d'autres fronts le front de
l'information le front du cyber et
surtout le front économique et donc on
est engagé les russes nous ont la peau
nous ont placés devant une épreuve de
force qui est une épreuve de force
principalement militaire contre
l'ukraine on est obligé de répondre par
une autre preuve de force qui est plus
global et notamment économiques en un
mot sommet européen à partir de ce cet
après midi à versailles en france si
l'embargo sur les hydrocarbures russes
n'est pas actée est-ce que ça serait
pour vous un échec de ce front européen
dont on dit depuis quinze jours qui les
unis comme jamais non ce ne sera pas un
échec et je vous le dire il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on dit alors les
journalistes font leur travail qu'ils
disent ce qu'ils veulent mais les
gouvernements doivent être attentifs il
peut y avoir il y aura encore entre les
différentes puissances occidentales des
différences de tactique sur tel ou tel
point il faut pas transformer ces
différences de tactique rendent un
gouffre catastrophique de divergence
j'ai vu ça sur la fir swiss va par
exemple vous moment donné on a
l'impression que c'était la fin de
l'occident parce qu'on n'était pas
d'accord exactement sur swift finalement
on à surmonter nos divergences et même
si on les avait pas
surmonter ça n'aurait pas changé grand
chose à ce front cohérent je dis que
c'est d'autant plus important que dans
le spes de dialogue ou implicite avec la
russie tout pas non plus que les russes
se trompent exclu quand même des choses
qui font fréquemment et donc ils peuvent
eux mêmes en tirer des conclusions
erronées sur la détermination des
occidentaux je ne fais que poser des
questions merci beaucoup monsieur michel
duclos d'être venu ce matin sur le
plateau de paris direct la france dans
le bouleversement du monde aux éditions
de l'observatoire plus que d'actualité
merci encore bonne journée à vous